welcome back to CBS mornings on this
final weekend before the midterms both
parties have big names on the campaign
Trail and last night President Biden
spoke in California while former
president Trump traveled to Iowa and you
may notice they had different messages
they're trying to suppress the right to
vote and subverted to our elections you
can't call yourself a democracy or
supporting Democratic principles if you
say the only elections fair is the one I
win we will stop the crime wave and
democrat-run cities we will give our
police the power they need and the
respect they deserve and we will not
take legal protection away from our
police they want to take away protection
of a policeman or woman has a problem
they want them to go out and get their
own lawyer no we're not doing that
we're joined Now by CBS News political
analyst and Republican strategist Leslie
Sanchez and also CBS News political
contributor Ashley Etienne I didn't know
you were now a contributor
congratulations
I'm excited hey very nice if you say
that at the end
welcome to both you Ashley let's start
with you uh Democrats and Republicans
very different closing messages uh
Democrats want to make it about the
future of democracy democracy is on the
line but the polls suggest that the
economy is top of mind for voters so are
Democrats Doing It Wrong well I mean
we're hitting on both messages we're not
walking away from the economy at all but
democracy is at stake I mean as the
president has said but you know one way
to look at this is that it's actually
working when you look at early voting
happening right now if people feel like
democracy is being threatened they're
going to run out to the polls and that's
what's happening all over the country in
states that really matter like Georgia
Ohio early vote numbers are up Democrats
are feeling very encouraged by that
because you know the the larger the
turnout the better it is for Democrats
so the idea now is to to not just uh to
to focus more on the low propensity
voters now that we're turning out
hyperpensity voters so I think democracy
is what we should be hitting on and
actually I was so excited to talk to you
that actually I forgot to give you your
due you are uh you were communications
director for vice president Kamala
Harris and also for Nancy Pelosi so your
insights are significant here and I'll
seed the floor thank you Leslie I'm
going to go to you because we've that
Latino voters right now are really the
Republicans are making big inroads with
them do we know what message
specifically might be resonating sure
there's a there's a lot of significance
about the Latino working class that is
realigning like the white working class
in this country and supporting more of a
popular conservative message that they
saw under Donald Trump so you see this
these kind of new candidates who've
emerged who were very supportive of uh
outer suburb working class families on
very conservative values and they're
resonating particularly in South Texas
you're seeing a diversity of candidates
as well that are running so Republicans
are optimistic about this but it's not
just going to be in Texas as States like
Texas you'll start to see it in Nevada
Arizona Colorado States and some of
those battles some of those battle
rounds where it's not you know a
thousand votes it's several hundred
votes and Latinos can make the
difference and speaking of optimism you
know we saw this shift this summer from
the Democrats uh having some momentum
and now the Republicans what are the
Democrats seeing on the ground that is
caused for some optimism well I'll just
say first let me caution over investing
in polling right polls don't vote people
actually vote okay there was never a
poll in 2016 that ever predicted Donald
Trump was going to be the president so I
think we should just level sit with
American people on that issue but you
know on the ground as I mentioned
earlier 34 million people are voting
have already early voted that's good for
democracy that's good from the Democrats
perspective for the party so a lot of
optimism and enthusiasm on the ground
long lines in Georgia long lines in
Pennsylvania so we're feeling very
encouraged by that as results start
rolling in on Tuesday night what races
will each of you be watching as a
barometer of where the overall night may
go uh Leslie go ahead first sure I was
talking previously about Texas Texas has
three Latinos running in the Rio Grande
Valley our home state we're very proud
of that and they're really tough in the
sense that they've taken on their own
political party they've raised a
tremendous amount of money outside the
state Texas and and they're against some
incumbents who face some scandals
different challenges so the area for for
these three particular Latinas is great
but if you start to see movement also in
Oregon and New York areas that are
deeper blue and Republicans don't
necessarily say today they can win but I
think there's going to be a lot of
incumbents on the Democratic side who
have some challenges now Ashley there
has been some disapproval of President
Biden now we see they've dispatched yes
some they've dispatched Obama out there
and he's back in his bag doing what he
does best right but our candidates are
they hesitant to attest themselves to
Biden in A Moment Like This I was
absolutely not I mean the president has
done I I don't know the number of time
in my head but he's hit all of major
Battleground States
um so but here's why is Obama out there
well because people love and adore Obama
and he's fantastic on this dump but but
here's here's the point that I would
like to make you know all races are
local right and so when you're the
president and you're up and you're
facing a midterm election the most
important thing for you to do I'm going
to use the sports analogy is to really
set up the assist and so for oh yeah
thank you
that might be the end of my knowledge of
sports but nevertheless but the idea is
that you set up the assist and the
assist is he's established a record that
no matter which state or how competitive
the races are there's something you can
talk about of course you know the
economy is doing better record of low
unemployment 10 million jobs created
right shots and arms veterans Health
Care lower health care costs all of that
so he's kind of equipped the candidates
to localize these races in a way that I
think we'll see some we'll be surprised
one state that if Democrats when you
feel like okay we're good I'm watching
Nevada so yeah I'm watching Stephen
horseford's race in Los Angeles in Las
Vegas right it's going to matter for the
for Cortez Mastro so that's the one I'm
watching and he's young he's won in
competitive races before is the future
of the party right yeah
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it come back soon yes of
course all right